non vous ne rêvez pas ce sont bien des
dizaines de petits cavaliers que vous
pouvez apercevoir devant le parc du
château de dampierre ses cavaliers
juniors faisait partie du programme équi
rando organisée le premier week-end
d'août et qui endosse est une
manifestation de la fédération française
d'équitation qui réunit sur un week-end
de des randonneurs cavaliers et leurs
équidés pour leur faire découvrir une
région parmi eux 70 enfants de 7 à 14
ans étaient rassemblés autour de l'est
qui rendent aux kids ses cavaliers
partent des semaines voire des mois
auparavant pour se rejoindre en un point
pour le plus grand rassemblement
européen de tourisme équestre
cette année au haras des bréviaires
l'equirando c'est d'abord se promener à
cheval se promener à cheval dans ce
superbe territoires d'île de france que
sont le département des yvelines est
plus spécialement bien les alentours de
ce haras des bréviaires situé à
proximité de rambouillet le principe de
l'écran dos c'est faire au minimum 100
km à cheval 100 km à cheval pour se
rendre à ce lieu de festivités et nous
allons les onze régions françaises qui
sont représentés mais également neuf
pays européens qui nous vend le plaisir
d'être avec nous pour ce superbe
week-end plus de 700 et qui rendent un
dont une quarantaine d'étrangers
ils sont sportifs en compétition ou
amateurs de randonnée et ils sont
rassemblés autour d'un seul thème la
passion du cheval comme le note b
et nous avons pris la route là par
feuille dans la montagne bourbonnaise
on est parti de chamant bosse donc dans
le loiret nous sommes partis de leurs
champs en dans le 77 en bordure de forêt
de fontainebleau fait étape à vide
poches de jouer pour l'équipe
ces quatre jours de randonnées
programmées à travers les paysages du
parc château fort les vaux de cernay
rambouillet en passant par le château de
la madeleine avant d'arriver au haras
des bréviaires
une arrivée en fanfare au haras puis
quelques vérifications vétérinaire avant
de commencer les festivités pendant
trois jours animations rencontres et
concerts étaient au programme de cet
événement international
les animations il ya du tir à l'arc à
cheval
des démonstrations
l'épicier mai
spectacle équestre avec entre autres
pierre fleury
très heureux d'accueillir cet artiste
cette année
le groupe récréation équestre avec un
spectacle sur les chevaux du monde
le pas de deux de dôme à baqueira et
enfin le pas de 4 de la guerre de
républicaine
[Musique]
pendant toute la durée de l'événement un
village des exposants permettait à
chacun de découvrir des spécialités
d'acheter des nouveaux produits ou tout
simplement de faire des rencontres
le clou du spectacle c'était le grand
défilé des équipes en vain dans
rambouillet des cavaliers à cheval à
poney à dos de mule des calèches et
autres choses attelage qui ont fait le
show dans les rues de la ville et devant
le château de rambouillet fort de son
succès depuis 1961
tous les deux ans les qui rendent au
continue de mettre en valeur une région
on vous donne rendez-vous en 2021 au
parc départemental de l'isle-briand au
lion d'angers dans le val de loire pour
la 53ème édition